Hi I'm Ramazan Salman. I'm social to Zentrum
in Germany. I learned much of things and I
got much of impulses with this. And most important
thing I learned here is that to beat the economic
crisis, to deal with the economic crisis,
not money is the most important thing. I think
the most important thing is to have one voice,
one idea, which brings all the people together,
which motivates all the people to work together
and to work against the crisis. And as is
result, one result is cooperation of civil
society sector, of economic sector, of political
sector, and of sanctity sector. There is no
sustainable solution possible against the
crisis. And while we work against the crisis
it's very important to remember that there
are people who are not bankers or financial
directors. There are much of people who are
workers, who are simple people
[pause]
We have to find a way to work the best together
to work against the crisis. It's not only
a crisis on the economic sector, it's a world
wide crisis which influence the social, the
educational, the head sector. It influences
every part of society sectors in this world.
The other thing is, and I want to say thank
you to the politicians and the economists,
that I feel that in a realistic way there
are enough answers founded and their reactions.
I'm impressed that a little depression is
feasible but at the end it's feasible to a
serious reaction. And I think the idea of
working world wide together in an institution
who is organizing the transfer of money, who
is controlling the money transfers and so
on, to work in this international institution,
this idea is born.. I think nearly in 10 years
we would have such and institution. I remember
the speech of Angelo American, she said as
a very strong nation, she's sure that the
states have to give some responsibility from
themselves to insure organization. And that
makes me a little bit optimistic because if
such an important and strong leader said that
she has to give the responsibility away then
I think it's a very strong message and I think
if other strong countries use this message
then I think we will do much of things.
[pause]
The other thing which impressed me is the
idea that Mr. Schwab told several times, that
if you rebuild our economic system then we
are to use the chance to make it better than
before. It's not unnecessary to reorganize
it in the same way. Maybe this time we reorganize
in a more ethical way, in a more serious way.
And so I think it's a good key message to
say we make it now better than before.
[pause]
And don't forget the third world, don't forget
the poor countries. I'm sure that it's necessary
that if we have problems with money now then
we have to think about third world. It's necessary
not to stop the transfer of money to them.
I'm very impressed that Germany decided in
this situation to give more to the third world.
It's impressive. Yes we have come together
in Davos. Five days, five days we are together.
And I think we want nearly three years because
of all the important actors come together
and they can do a lot with in five days. They
can get impulses in five days. They can get
ideas and strategies in five days. Normally
I think we need for these strategies one,
two, or three years. And I want to say thank
you to Mr Schwab who made it possible. And
I think every time we need one man saying,
ok there's the way we go there. And then we
all together go to there and find solutions
in which we have all together compromised.
Thank you very much.